les Gardiens de la Galaxie
n'ont pas leur place dans mon monde embrasse ta mère
avec ce visage les
coins sonores de l'univers le considèrent que
Dieu
s'affronte
bien, je suppose que nous mourrons en essayant,
j'ai décidé d'essayer et ce n'est plus une chose que le
public soit
détruit, va
te faire [ __ ]  tu étires le visage de
RoboCop qui a l'air
violet nurple paix
tu ne sais pas tu penses
sanglant dans le Galaxy vol 3 prêt billets PG-13
jusqu'à maintenant attends attends
attends
vas-y
j'avais huit ans quand je suis parti de là
tu veux que je conduise non je  Je vais
découvrir comment le mettre à l'envers
selon les billets Galaxy Vol 380pg-13
en vente maintenant